[Music]
you
hi table family this is my to welcome
you to our service my name is Don Jacobs
and I want to welcome you to our very
first addition to pride for for our
church service today this is one of
those things I'm a little surreal that
I'm even just saying this in a church
setting but I'm very thankful that we
are in a place where all of just
everybody is just welcome we can say
that and just legitimately mean that so
just one welcome anybody who kind of
identifies LGBTQ or anything else on
that spectrum that you are fully
included and just with what you know
that you were loved insane I do you have
one quick announcement that I'm gonna
make here in a second but I also want to
just kind of mention this week has been
kind of interesting it has been a week
where I have done a lot of listening
I've been doing a lot of trying to hear
where people that I care about very
deeply where they're just hurting and
it's just been crazy that we still are
having these conversations about racism
and how that's affecting our country our
world and just even in individual lives
and and when I stop and really think
about it I really think that we should
be further along than we are
but then I start reading Scripture and I
see that it's Jesus dealt with this it
was even before Jesus came under the
scene it was still an issue so it just
really impresses upon me that this is
something that at least for me I need to
make sure that I am in a posture just
constantly listening and learning I am
trying to make action take action steps
that helps make things the same for
everyone and so I hope I hope that you
guys that some of you have been somewhat
encouraged by listening system of the
voices that have been going on this last
week
so I do one quick announcement I want to
talk about um you know since we've been
talking about me that UPS the last
several weeks I want to give that kind
of a shout out to a meet-up that Marissa
and I have been doing for the last
couple of months so the reason when we
started this meetup was because we knew
the table was a little bit new and we
wanted a place where we could talk about
church and some of our experiences with
church and how at the table things might
look a little bit different than when we
were we came from and so we've been
actually going through a study that's
through this book by Rachel held Evans
it's called searching for Sunday and
it's Rachel story about webbing and
leaving and finding the church and so
this has been actually very has started
some very interesting conversations with
all of us that have been part of our
group and even though we are kind of in
a book study we try our best to make
sure that we include anybody who stopped
as StepStone for the very first time
that they can still participate in the
conversation so if that's something you
might be interested in and you just want
to just to kind of check it out and see
what it is or anything like that feel
free to do so you can reach out to me my
email will be in the comments below and
we will kind of get you guys connected
and we will send you links and just add
you to our conversations you can be a
part of I'm going to say a quick prayer
and then we look we will get started
with our service let's pray lord I just
want to thank you so much for this
opportunity this time the ability to be
able to be in the setting where we can
open up our hearts and minds to you and
to what you have to say for us in this
space especially given what's been going
on in our country and around the world I
prayed that you will just speak to us in
our hearts help us to know what you're
what you're wanting us to do moving
forward how we should
respond how you would like us to engage
in this conversation and I pray that you
will just be with this the SEC upcoming
this message
I pray that used to be with Brett as he
sharing and that our hearts and minds
are open in Christ and I pray amen
so glad for those of you who are with us
biking the twin power this is not
planned but we are really vitamin
tonight on the fuzzy button and the
wooden earrings anyways moving on we're
gonna spend some time singing together
and we want you guys to take this moment
to you can
[Music]
my god
in the darkness my god
[Music]
you
that is
[Music]
I don't see is your work you and I don't
feel it your work and then you never
stop you never stop learning you never
stop never stop working you know and I
don't see you working here when I don't
feel that you're working you never stop
never stop never stop never stop me
you never stop learning
[Music]
I just wanted to share with you guys as
I know so many of us have been
experiencing just a lot of emotions I
was just finding myself very
disappointed and a little bit in
grieving mode and then also a little bit
so centered and I was just you know
[Music]
it's going on around us racially and
just my heart being so heavy and
sometimes not knowing what to do with
all those emotions are you know how to
move us forward and who to be part of a
change that I want to see so excited
because I was supposed to go to this
rally protest this morning and just
feeling like there was some sort of
[Music]
picture for nothing else is gonna be
there of color to see this white person
anyway
[Music]
this is gone
that's missing words in this bridge I
just
[Music]
[Applause]
the holding back the seat should I ever
need remind me how you been to me I
can't the joint come everybody I count
the joy
[Music]
that's even when I don't see you to work
you know when I don't feel that you're
working we never stop you never stop
working you never stop you never stop
our game even when I don't see that you
are you and I don't feel it you were
table you never stop you never stop
working you never stop you never stop
[Music]
our continued
helped us to love the way that you do
it's in your name I pray
[Music]
good evening my friends grace in peace
welcome to the table a huge thank you to
all the folks that came before me we
have Gary doing the in the background
doing tech and then of course Maggie and
Mindy and on music in John it's
wonderful to have you doing our welcome
I love it and then shout out to Matthew
for playing his amazing piano at the
beginning so thank you to everyone who's
contributed to help make this service
possible and to all of you the listeners
our community Watchers and listeners we
love you us and are so grateful to have
you with us tonight so we are a
community that's committed to being
thoughtful inclusive eclectic communal
and vulnerable those are values and from
living those out we seek to shift a
generation from reactionary to visionary
through the person in work of Jesus
that's our mission that's who we are
it's what we're about and so if you are
just joining us maybe for the first time
that's a little bit of a taste of who we
are and I hope that the whole service in
this message really communicates that so
before we before we jump in though I do
want to just name that our Christianity
is hoping to resume in person our
meetups or small groups this month
that's kind of our hope the numbers for
Texas have been good even for like
Collin County a lot of the counties have
been quite good Dallas County which is
the one technically our churches in not
so good
but still we are kind of hoping for that
so I'm gonna be sending out a
communication on that this this week to
our church so if you if you aren't on
our email list and you'd like to be um
check us a message on our Facebook or a
website the table to x.org in the
contact page and just let us know now
that is different than my weekly letter
um so you know I don't send out church
specific emails to like you know the
whole list generally so that's specific
if you kind of consider your selfie but
they're part of the table or just so
many wants stay in the loop and and more
of the details then let us know and
we'll get you on that so we are in the
let's say it's the fourth and the final
part of our series titled lament giving
voice to our grief and the title of my
message this week is a pain transformed
so our scripture today it comes from
Psalm chapter 137 137 and if you were
with us a few weeks ago then you'll
understand the context for this passage
in a pretty deep deep way but I'll give
you a little snippet for those who
weren't here so the story goes that
historically so the Jewish people just
prior to the writing of this text they
have been conquered by the Babylonian
Empire thousands of them have been
killed thousands have been exiled and
scattered throughout really the the
entire Babylonian Empire and it was an
absolute national catastrophe so that's
the context for this Psalm which is
written from the perspective of someone
who who no longer lives in their their
their home their hometown Jerusalem so
they're now they've been exiled to now
they're living somewhere in Babylon so
we pick up up the text there in verse
one Psalm 137 verse one by the rivers of
Babylon we sat in wept when we
remembered Zion and that's a Zion is
another term for Jerusalem there on the
poplars we hung our harps
for there our captors asked us for songs
our tormentors demanded songs of joy
they said sing us when the songs of Zion
how how can we sing the songs of the
Lord while in a foreign land so I've
been kind of reflecting on on our series
and I've been wondering
particularly cuz I'm not in person you
know with you in the same way I've been
I've been wondering how how it has
landed for you I wonder if it's been
cathartic in in helpful I wonder if it
has been depressing I wonder I wonder at
times if people have maybe even like a
misunderstood lament or or perhaps not
even like misunderstand it but simply
have no really understanding at all of
lemon and what it's all about at least
in the biblical sense the way we've been
unpacking it because yes lament is
complaint yes lament is is a groan
lament is is saying this is not how the
world should be but the point of lament
is not to to create rage and righteous
indignation because it's too late for
that the righteous indignation is
already there it's already present in
our minds in our bodies the point of
lament is not to somehow you know
encourage discouragement and depression
to descend upon us like a cloud because
again it's too late for that for many of
us
discouragement depression anxiety angst
are already surrounding us Mindi put
that so beautifully earlier right it's
it's too late too late for that and and
this is what I think perhaps critics of
Lumet miss right because they're all
like whoa you're just gonna bring
everyone down but what they don't
realize is that it's too late
we're already down maybe not everyone
but many of us right we're already down
we already feel kicked to the curb
already have a creeping sense of despair
already feel disempowered already
watched the news and wonder what can I
do to change this already look at our
lives and wonder how am I going to put
this back together in fact this is why I
think one of the reasons we listen to
sad music it's not because we want to be
sad but because there's a part of us
exhaust always already kind of grieving
and hurting for the world that's why we
we resonate with it so in other words
there's no point in like playing pretend
we might as well face it straight on we
might as well learn this is what limit
says we might as well learn to speak
honestly and if we do this long enough
and faithfully enough if we become truth
speakers and rather than silencing
ourselves instead we speak the truth to
God and to others that we need to speak
what do we find
happens our pain is transformed our pain
is transformed by a loving God and a
community as we talked in a previous
week's of faithful listeners our pain is
transformed into life transforming
action that's the end game of lament
lament does not end in complaint it ends
in faith and there is a connection
between Psalm 137 in the following
chapter Psalm 138 yeah lo and behold 138
comes after yeah and I think it models
this I'm really perfectly so as we just
read Psalm 137 is is this someone deeply
depressed and in ways it's almost kind
of cliche almost what their what they're
doing so it
37 verse 1 says by the rivers of Babylon
we sat and wept when we remembered Zion
there on the poplars we hung our harps
so a poplar this is a tree and you can
see the image here now I guess there are
kind of I'd say maybe two ways to
interpret this one is in in a sense of
an appropriate season of lament right
where it's not like if you think of a
harp it plays beautiful music presumably
happy music and so the image of hanging
your heart up on the tree couldn't be
kind of a season of lemon where it's
like look up it's just not time to sing
the praise songs you know so you hang up
the heart um but there there is I think
another way to read this which is maybe
where you hang up your heart for good
can you see the image there um so so
that this person is psalmist they're
hanging up up their heart they're
hanging up their song their joy their
hope their worship their faith they're
hanging up and and I say it's that like
in the vast sense it could be a little
bit cliche because I'm thinking of like
the 100 movies that are out there you
know where the hero is like that's it
that's it I'm done I'm done right
because and it's sort of almost the the
image of like the sports athlete you
know who maybe loses the championship
game and even though they're still in
their prime this am I'm hanging up my
cleats or the musician who says songs no
I don't write songs anymore I'm done
with songs songs have only let me down
and then they hang up their guitar or
the poet who rips up their poems and
declares they're through the leader who
resigns their position I'm done this bow
suit prematurely files the divorce
papers where the activist who throws
away their signs they're they're hanging
it up right in anyways at times we've
all been there and some of you are there
right now you're like this
on world here's I'm done and and up go
our hearts unto the trees now
technically a psalm chapter 138 has no
connection to Psalm 137 two different
Psalms um possibly two different writers
no connection and yet
it is interesting that they were
intentionally chosen to sit back to back
and I also don't think that that was a
coincidence because read together they
they exhibit this this move that we see
over and over and over again the Psalms
which is the move from lament to praise
in fact this is why some people like
psychologists have done like a
psychological mean of the Psalms and
they've accused the psalmist's of being
written by like a bipolar person I'm
like not joking because right because if
you've ever read the Psalms you know
they're like oh you know I'm enraged God
is nowhere and then three verses later
and Lord you a faithful untrue and that
may sound a little bit like what is
going on but that's I mean I think
actually that's really good like a
really good description of what it's
like to be human right where I doubt God
and I pray to him at the same time I
questioned God and yet trust that he
will come through this this process this
is what the scholar Walter Brueggemann
who we've talked about a number of times
in the series he calls it the transition
from disorientation to reorientation
that's the process in the Psalms and
specifically the Psalms of lament now
disorientation is what I just described
right it's when when I hang up my harp
on the tree disorientation is Psalm 137
verses one through four and and so but
here's what's interesting we go from
Psalm 137 verse four says how can we
sing the songs of the Lord while in a
foreign land and then to just a few
verses later Psalm 138 someone who
apparently is still in a foreign land as
you'll see in a moment
they talk about singing before other
lowercase G gods they talk about bowing
down before like or toward the temple
not in the temple so this is what it
says some 138 I will praise you Lord
with all of my heart before the gods I
will sing your praise I will bow down
toward your holy temple and will praise
your name for your unfailing love in
your faithfulness for you have so
exalted your solemn decree that it
surpasses your fame when I called you
answered me you greatly emboldened me
and what I'm aiming tonight is that this
this transition from lament to praise
from disorientation to reorientation
from fear to action is is not only
necessary but but what I mean is that
lament actually helps to facilitate this
process that when we lament we speak our
pain to a loving God in a community of
faithful listeners and we find a
transformation happening in our souls
and thank God for this like for this
process because as father Richard Rohr
he puts this really powerful he says if
we do not transform our pain we will
surely transmit it usually to those
closest to us our family our neighbors
our co-workers and invariably the most
vulnerable our children see that's the
question facing all of us will we
transform our pain or will we transmit
our pain will we do the work to move
from lament into a place of praise and
action or will we stop that complaint in
moaning I I think of my friend Steven el
vaso
some of you know him for years
he dealt and by the way I got permission
from all the people I'm about to talk
about got from Steven four years so he
dealt with
of an abusive father and the death of
his brother and he dealt with this by
running to drugs and other addictive
substances but it wasn't until he faced
into his pain turned to God in
repentance in Dan prays that his pain
was transformed
rather than transmitted I think of our
very own Don Jacobs Sioux you've all got
to see earlier wrestling with his
identity as a game man and the theology
he was raised with that said God hated
him but what's happening he is slowly
learning to accept himself in the
reality that God loves him and he's now
taking that pain and he's transforming
it into leadership as you mentioned he's
now leading a meet-up that helps others
encounter the grace in the love of God
themselves I think of our very own care
and miner realizing that to be white in
America is to exist with a certain level
of inbuilt privilege and she's now
leading our be the bridge course that
that is basically it's a racial
awareness study group and what's so
powerful is that in in each of these
instances these folks they're all moving
from a place of disorientation to
reorientation from lament to praise from
fear to action no as we touched on last
week though this this isn't only about
the ways that you know like we as
individuals might lament and then find
you know our own personal individual
healing and there is something deeper
that happens
as well and I think a hint of that depth
is evident not so much in on the surface
of the Psalms themselves as it is in the
way the Psalms of lament came to be used
over time you see it's very possible
that many of these Psalms were written
by individuals wrestling with their own
personal struggles in other words in
many Psalms there's like the psalmist
and then there's God but but what
happened over time well these Psalms
made their way into communities of faith
and suddenly they became communal events
you see to lament as a Christian is not
simply to lament as an isolated
individual but it is to lament in the
context of a community and what happens
to the listeners as they engage my
lament that they are push-push to
determine a faithful response and when I
think of what prompted us to start the
table it dawned on me that that's that's
a key part of what happened we were in
community with LGBTQ people and suddenly
their laments forced us to determine a
faithful response in last Sunday we
talked extensively about the murder of
George Floyd and I do not know exactly
how that landed on all the ears of the
white members of our community but what
did that time of Lynette do it forced us
to face the question what does a
faithful response look like and it push
some of you some of you who have never
posted politically on social media you
did that this week and it pushed others
to attend a protest or to call their
congressman or woman and on and on and
on and so as as we journey
ahead what I want you to consider well
consider this sermon a call to not only
lament but a call to action in the weeks
and the months ahead I want us to start
figuring out how we can help bring both
love and justice to our city let's make
a decision to be eight people who
transform our pain rather than
transmitted will you pray with me
or Jesus our hearts cry is to be a
church that can honestly lament that can
speak the truth I can say the
uncomfortable word the honest word and
god I pray that through that that it
would transform us and I pray for over
every person listening God who right now
they're just in a place of deep sorrow
grief struggle I pray that that as they
they speak that truth out in a community
of faithful listeners that their pain
would be transformed and for all of
those who are in a place where they're
they're ready to move forward to work
for justice I pray that you would lead
them lead us to wise in faithful action
but continue to do that work in our
hearts the name of Jesus I pray amen so
in closing um in this season I want to
just kind of give I guess give us a few
little calls to action as a church we'll
be in in coming months figuring out
broader ways to do this but but for now
if you're just looking for something to
do tonight I want to mention two
opportunities for you the first is to
donate to five loaves food pantry this
is an organization in saxy
and in the light of everything with
kovat 19 in the downturn in the economy
the this I was talking with Audrey who
helps to run this and they are
definitely running low on food she said
they're basically just anything we could
do to donate whether financially or to
give food they would be greatly just
just really appreciative so I didn't
write you can donate there you can also
donate to the Dallas truth
racial healing and transformation a
nonprofit organization this is a
community working at the intersection of
racial injustice in and in Dallas and so
we this is basically yeah just to kind
of opportunities in ways for you to get
involved you can also research those
other is Asians and maybe like donate
time and energy I know they would
greatly appreciate it so we're gonna go
ahead and transition over to some more
music so I love you all have a wonderful
wonderful week
[Music]
and the basis seemed to share together
of the fool and both it seems is I don't
feel you anymore yes I don't feel you
anymore I need a reason to know that
you're still holding
[Music]
I need a reason and I hate everything I
know if this waiting lasts forever and
I'm afraid I'm - yeah I'm afraid I might
[Music]
reason the reason to see I need to know
that you're still holding the whole
world in your
I need a reason
[Music]
victory will you sing it over me
your piece is the melody will you sing
it all
[Music]
will you sing your piece will you sing
it all I need a reason to see I need a
reason to see I need to know that you're
still holding the whole this is the
reason to see
[Music]
I just want to thank everyone for
joining us tonight
and then just remind everyone of the
ways that Brett can I mentioned to to
contribute to some action pieces so it's
the five loaves food pantry and the
Dallas truth were racial healing and
transformation organization so links
will be below in the comments so be sure
to check those out and then as we close
tonight I do want to send you out on
this Franciscan blessing for justice may
God bless you with the restless
discomfort about easy answers
half-truths and superficial
relationships so you may seek truth
boldly and love deep within your heart
may God bless you with holy anger at
injustice oppression and exploitive
people so you may tirelessly work for
justice freedom and peace among all
people may God bless you with a gift of
tears to shed for those who suffer pain
rejection starvation or the loss of all
that they cherish so that you may reach
out your hand to comfort them to
transform their pain into joy and may
God bless you with enough faith
fortitude and courage to believe that
you are you really can make a difference
in this world so that you are able with
God's grace to do what others claims
cannot be done so believe less and have
a good night
you